combien de temps combien de temps
allons-nous continuer continuer à croire
que 100 blessés graves par jour ça n'est
pas si grave que ça
continuez à croire que réparer les corps
peut suffire à réparer les vies
continuez à croire que ceux qui
survivent pourront revivre comme avant
continuez à croire qu'un accident de la
route ne dure qu'une seconde
alors qu'il peut durer toute une vie
continuez à croire que derrière chaque
corps blessés il n'y a qu'une seule vie
blessés continuent à croire que les
accidents de la route sont une fatalité
alors que c'est à nous d'agir pour les
éviter rendre la route plus sûre ne
dépend que de nous merci à marius
sébastien cyril alan maryse franck
aurélien et à leur entourage pour leur
participation à ce film
mobilisons-nous à leurs côtés